Kristen is with us in New Mexico hi
Kristen welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi how are you better than I deserve
what's up well my husband and I use
credit cards and we normally pay the
balance off at the end of the month
sometimes but with all but with all of
this did you hear me
yeah I said I'm sorry
so with all of this my husband is in
sales and his income has gone down and
I'm wondering if we should pay off the
full balance of our credit card or if we
should not and just pay the minimum or
just a certain amount towards them and
get keep as much money as we can
are you employed outside the home yes
what do you make I make 90,000 what's
the balance on the credit card it's
5,000 you should pay it off and you
should cut it up yes we are using yes
for sure yes okay use debit cards in the
future meaning that you will never have
to ask this question again because you
will only purchase things that you can
afford to buy yes for sure yeah that's
what we will do yeah you've got to do
nothing $5,000 is not going to change
your life right I yeah I just worry a
lot that his income will be cut and then
we'll have to rely on just what we have
in savings and then yeah but what does
he make yeah he makes seventy five okay
so you have a hundred and fifty five
thousand dollar household income if his
income is cut in half
you're not gonna have to use savings
unless you've got debt coming out your
ears you just tell you know we actually
paid off all of our debt so we don't
have any great okay well if you have a
hundred fifty five thousand our income
with no debt the only possible way you
would have to dip into savings is if you
don't cut off stuff like 401ks
I mean if things go down you cut off all
ancillary things and you tighten the
budget up right and you take care of the
most
important things first food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities
and then you work on minimal other stuff
and with a hundred and fifty five
thousand even with that income coming
down to a hundred thousand and it won't
come that far down I mean he'd be
looking for the job he went down to
twenty thousand so you're gonna you're
gonna be fine you're gonna be fine
the good news is this kind of got to be
your wake-up call you but hey I was kind
of screwing around doing ish with this
credit card and now it's chopped hmm
there we go chop chop baby plastic
surgery thanks for the call there is a
thing that happens in the human psyche
when we transform spiritually
emotionally mental health whatever lens
you want to look at it in order for
transformation to occur there has to be
something that happens that says the
current status is worse than the pain of
change because change is painful mm-hmm
and for us to engage in change the
current status has to get bad enough
that hey we'll try anything I'll try
something new I'll do something
different because current sucks bad
enough that I'd rather have changed then
I would what I got now and a whole bunch
of folks are sitting there right now
this is a wonderful opportunity for some
of you to utilize the pain that you're
feeling the stress that you're feeling
as you're as you're starting to change
and transform your life particularly in
the area of money and you just say never
again this is your never again moment
there's a beautiful thing about the
brain that can be frustrating too that
says what's familiar is safe and so
anytime our routines get disrupted the
things that we think we know get
disrupted it just sets off all of our
alarms and so the quicker you can get to
a new normal the quicker you can get to
saying no more then everything starts to
settle down you got a new trajectory you
can go get it but that's why people stay
in crummy jobs that's why they stay in
crappy marriages and they don't they
don't challenge a you know abusive
spouses because the it it's safe because
it's familiar right that's the way our
wiring is and so once you get out of
that
suddenly the world shakes and like a
snow globe and you find yourself stuck
now you're on a new path and the quicker
you can get on that new path and say
never again I'm running just to bring it
down so that little ding and his
commissions could be the wake-up call
that that whole household sits down and
gets pushed out of the familiar and says
I know I'm never gonna be here again
what a gift
yeah it is a gift he changes over